I have a special episode for you this time around. We're coming to you live from PyCon 2024. I had
the chance to sit down with some amazing people from the data science side of things. Jody Burchill,
Maria Jose Molina Contreras, and Jessica Green. We cover a whole set of recent topics from a data
science perspective. Though we did have to cut the conversation a bit short as they were coming
from and going to talks they were all giving, but it's still a pretty deep conversation. I know you'll
enjoy it. This is Talk Python to Me, episode 467 recorded on location in Pittsburgh on May 18th, 2024.
Are you ready for your host, Darius? You're listening to Michael Kennedy on Talk Python to Me.
Live from Portland, Oregon, and this segment was made with Python.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python. This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the podcast using @talkpython,
both on fosstodon.org. Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at
talkpython.fm. We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified about upcoming shows and be part of
that episode. This episode is brought to you by Sentry. Don't let those errors go unnoticed. Use
Sentry like we do here at Talk Python. Sign up at talkpython.fm/sentry. And it's brought to you by
Code Comments, an original podcast from Red Hat. This podcast covers stories from technologists
who've been through tough tech transitions and share how their teams survived the journey.
Episodes are available everywhere you listen to your podcast and at talkpython.fm/code-comments.
Hello from PyCon. Hello, Jessica, Jody, Maria. Welcome to Talk Python to Me. It's awesome to
have you all here. And I'm looking forward to talking about data science, some fun LLM questions
maybe, some controversial questions, some data science tools, all sorts of good things. Of course,
before we get to that, Jody, you've been on the show a time or two, and people may know you, but
maybe not. So how about a quick introduction, what you all are into? Maria, you want to start?
Oh, okay. Well, my name is Maria. I am originally from Barcelona, but I am based in Berlin. I work
as a data scientist in a small startup that we are trying to solve some sustainability problems.
And yeah, that is me. Excellent.
Yeah. So my name's Jody and I am a data science developer advocate. I've been working in data
science for about eight years. And yeah, I'm currently working at JetBrains, as you can see
from the shirt. And the background. And so I'd say my interest at the moment is natural language
processing, because I worked in that a big chunk of my career, but core statistics will always be
my love. So tabular data, I'm there for you always. Beautiful.
Yeah. My name's Jessica. So I'm an ML engineer at Coja, which is the search engine for a better
planet. I am actually a career changer. So I used to roast coffee for a living, and I really just
got into this field in the last six years. So I don't have like any formal training. I'm a community
slash self-taught engineer. And I went through more of a like a backend focused path. And now
I've started to work in the ML realm. So really exciting.
Yeah. Very, very interesting. Another thing I absolutely love is coffee.
I think we're running on it at PyCon.
Pretty much. We are. Yeah. We're getting farther into the show and more coffee is needed.
But I do want to ask you, what do you think about being in the data science space? That's a really
different world that interacting with people all day and working with your hands more or whatever.
Yeah. How has it been with this switch? There is a lot of synergies actually, when you're
stood behind the Espresso machine and you're getting all the orders in and then you need to
like problem solve to like how you get everyone their correct order to the way that they like it.
So there was a lot of transferable skills, I will say. But I think what I found really powerful,
especially maybe learning at this specific period of time, is how accessible a lot of the tools are
today. So like how, I wouldn't say easy because I put a lot of hard work into it, but like how
possible it is, even with a background like mine to get into the field.
Awesome. I switched, I didn't have a formal education either. I took two computer college
courses just because they match, you know, I needed for something else. And yeah, I thought,
I think you can completely succeed here teaching yourself. There's so many resources. Honestly,
the problem is what resources do you choose to learn these days, right? You can spend all your
time while I'm doing another tutorial, I'm doing another class, like some point you got to start
doing something, right? Yeah. And I think actually it felt like that probably when we all started.
So data science was just getting hot when I started and oh my God, back when I started,
this is how long ago it was. There were actually like those articles like R versus Python,
like there's no conversations anyone's having anymore, but they have similar conversations.
And I think it makes it super difficult for beginners because the field felt inaccessible,
I think, eight years ago. The field feels very hostile to beginners right now, I think,
because of the AI hype. I don't actually think the field has changed that much in fundamentals.
It's just NLP has become a bigger thing and computer vision recently, but we can get into that.
Yeah, I completely agree with half of you. To be honest, for me, data science is super broad
world full of a lot of things that are kind of popping up, doing different evolution during time.
And it's so interesting to see the evolution in the last eight years. I started eight years ago in
data science. And I remember when how I was doing things eight years ago, and how I'm doing things
now. And I love it. I love to see this progression. And I am pretty sure that in eight more years,
we're gonna be in something completely different. And so I totally agree with that.
I do. And I also think data science is interesting because coming into it, you can be a data
scientist, but because some other reason, right, I could be a data science because I'm interested in
biology or sustainability or something. Whereas you're if you're a web developer, or you build
API's, or you optimize, you know, whatever, you, you're more focused on I care about the thing at
the code itself, rather than I'm trying to I care about that. And this is a tool to address that.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, actually, I was gonna say, I met a bioinformatician yesterday,
like, that's also a data scientist, like someone who works in genetic data.
Yeah, absolutely. I had a comment from I did a show recently from about how Python's used in
neurology labs, right? And somebody wrote me, this is my favorite episode. It speaks to me.
I'm also a neurologist. Like, it's really cool. All right, we're looking out,
kind of the backside of the little bit. We're looking at the expo hall here at PyCon. So
I don't know about you all feel but for me, this is like my geek holiday, I get to come here. And
it's really special to me because I get to see my friends who I've collaborated with projects on,
and I admire and I've worked with, but I might never see them outside of this week, you know,
maybe they live in Australia or Europe or some oddly just down the street. And yet still,
I don't see them except here. So maybe what are your thoughts on PyCon here?
It's my first time attending. So I'm super stoked, I have to say like, it's slightly
overwhelming, because there's so many things going on. And like you mentioned, the opportunity to
meet so many folks that I either already knew in some capacity, but had never met or didn't meet
before, but have heard of their work. So yeah, it's been a real honor to be here, right? And get
to I mean, we are all based in Berlin. So we do actually know each other. But it's also a pleasure
just to come away on a geek holiday with friends. Yeah, and we were actually all just at PyCon DE
just before this, like a month ago. Yeah, well, yeah, it's it's a different scale. Let's put it
that way. But I think it's a similar feel like one thing that I value so much about the Python
community is that it's community. And I'm very lucky to have gotten involved in a program called
Hatchery, which you two have also been involved in. It's a Hatchery we're running is Humble Data.
And what I like is this program got accepted at a Python conference, which is designed for people
who have never coded and who are career changers, because I'm also a career changer from academia.
And this is what makes I think Python special, the community and I think the PyCons are an
absolute representation of that. Yeah, absolutely. For me, it's the same feeling I love to go to
different conferences of PyCon. And because we have a lot of things in common. But also,
we have differences and the different conferences bring a different point of value. And I think it's
awesome. I came here and meet friends that this is my third time in here. And I'm super, super
excited and happy. And I'm super eager to next year. And also the Python in Espanol. Yeah,
of course. And also we have even here we have a track that is PyCon charlas to be even more
welcoming to different people from different communities. And it's just amazing. It's super
nice, to be honest. Awesome. Yeah, I definitely want to encourage people out there listening
who feel like oh, I'm not high enough of a level of Python. I know to come. I'm not ready for PyCon.
I believe last year, I haven't heard any numbers this year. I believe last year 50% of the
attendees were first time attendees. And I think that's generally true. A lot of times people are
it's their first time coming and yeah, it's I think you can get a lot out of it even if you're
not super advanced, maybe even more so than if you are super advanced. I definitely have had
the opportunity like the honor, I would actually say to like listen into conversations around
topics that I find interesting, but aren't part of my day to day work. And it's just like general
vibe that whether it's at lunch or during the breaks or after a talk, you get to partake in
these conversations, which ultimately will advance you. So if you also want to get sponsoring,
right, like a lot of people need their work to sponsor them. I think there's a lot of reasoning
behind asking for PyCon as a conference because there's so much value. Jessica, that's a great
point. And I think also, I was talking to someone earlier about how much more affordable this is
than a lot of tech conferences. A lot of them are like, how many thousand dollars is just the ticket?
And this is not that cheap, but it's relatively cheap compared. So I was going to say you could
do a plug for EuroPython while you're here. We have also the option to have grants. There is a
different programs, PyLadiesGrants or the conference organizers grants. Also, this is
something that could help people to try to apply or come here. Yeah, they mentioned that at the
opening keynote or the introductions before the keynote. It's some significant number of grants
that were given. I can't remember the number, but it's like half a million dollars or something
in grants. Was that what it was? I think it was around that scale. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's a really
big deal. And I suppose all three of you being from Berlin, we should say generally the same
stuff applies to EuroPython as well, I imagine. Right? Yeah. So if you're in Europe, the biggest
deal is to get all the way to the US, maybe go to EuroPython as well, which would be fun. Yeah.
Or something more local. This portion of Talk Python to Me is brought to you by
OpenTelemetry support at Sentry. In the previous two episodes, you heard how we use Sentry's error
monitoring at Talk Python, and how distributed tracing connects errors, performance and slowdowns
and more across services and tiers. But you may be thinking, our company uses OpenTelemetry. So
it doesn't make sense for us to switch to Sentry. After all, OpenTelemetry is a standard, and you've
already adopted it, right? Did you know, with just a couple of lines of code, you can connect
OpenTelemetry's monitoring and reporting to Sentry's backend. OpenTelemetry does not come
with a backend to store your data, analytics on top of that data, a UI or error monitoring. And
that's exactly what you get when you integrate Sentry with your OpenTelemetry setup. Don't fly
blind, fix and monitor code faster with Sentry. Integrate your OpenTelemetry systems with Sentry
and see what you've been missing. Create your Sentry account at talkpython.fm/sentry-telemetry.
And when you sign up, use the code TALKPYTHON, all caps, no spaces. It's good for two free months of
Sentry's business plan, which will give you 20 times as many monthly events as well as other
features. My thanks to Sentry for supporting Talk Python and me. - Jody, you have been on the
receiving end of many, many questions and you've been, let's see here, doing demos, sworn with
people for a day and a half. I'm surprised you still have your voice. - I've got to give a talk
in two hours too, so I hope I have a voice. - Speak quietly. Save a little bit for that. One
of the questions you said was that people are still just have core data science questions.
They're not necessarily trying to figure out how LLMs are going to change the world, but how do
you do that with pandas or whatever? What are your thoughts on this? What are your takeaways? - So I
alluded to the fact I have an academic background. I've probably talked about this on the last
podcast, but basically my background is in behavioral sciences, so a lot of core statistics
and working with what's called tabular data, data in tables. And pretty much I would say, look, this
is a guesstimate. This is not scientific, but my kind of gut feeling, PyCon after PyCon, conference
after conference that I do, I think like 80% of people are probably still doing this stuff because
business questions are not necessarily solved with the cutting edge. Business questions are
solved with the simplest possible models that will address your needs. I think we talked about this in
the last podcast. So like for an example, my last job, we had to deal with low latency systems, like
very low latency. So we used a decision tree to solve the problem. Decision tree is a very old
algorithm. It's not sexy anymore, but everyone's secretly still using it. And so yeah, some people
are doing cutting edge LLM stuff. But my feeling is this is a technology that maybe has more interest
than real profitable applications, because these are expensive models to run and deploy and to set
up reliable pipelines for. Yeah. My feeling is, gut feeling is a lot of people are still just
doing boring linear regression, which I will defend until the day I die. My favorite algorithm.
Amazing. Yeah.
Yeah. And I mean, I think we've seen that in our work as well is we don't per se need the biggest,
fanciest thing. We need something that works and provides users with useful information. I think
there's also still a lot of problems with large language models, like Simon alluded to in the
keynote today around security. So if you want to put this into a product, it's still kind of early
days, but I don't think those base kind of NLP techniques are going to go away anytime soon.
And I think like we spoke about learners earlier and people coming into the field,
there's still a huge amount of value just to go and learn this core aspects that will serve
you really well. Absolutely. Way more than LLMs and AIs and all that stuff.
You can use a LLM to learn it. That's what we just saw in the keynote.
Yeah, absolutely. And I also think what people are going to do with LLMs and stuff like that,
ask it to help give me this little bit of code or that bit of code, but you're going to need to be
able to look at it and say, yeah, that does make sense. Yeah, that does fit in. And so you need to
know that's a reasonable use of pandas. What do you think, Maria? I completely agree. The LLM's
role is kind of complex. I think that it has a lot of potential. And I think that a lot of people
could see this potential and everyone is getting very excited and even a bit in a hype because of
that. However, it has a lot of limitations still nowadays, I can tell you, because I am currently
working with LLMs for solving the real world problems that we were mentioning about the
sustainable packaging. And it's very challenging, to be honest. It's more challenging that people
are mentioning. It's not only hallucinations, it's hallucinations, of course. But also,
if you are doing fine tuning models, also you're going to later on need to think how you're going
to deploy that, how much is going to cost you the inference of that, how it's going to cost in
terms of electricity price, CO2, print, and long, etc. I think that we are in the process.
I think we're at a very high hype cycle. I haven't seen anything like this since the dot com days
when pets.com was running around crazy and there was all sorts of bizarre Super Bowl ads just
showing, you know, we have enough money to just burn it on silly things because we're a dot com
company. And I think we're kind of back there. But to me, the weird thing is it's not 100 percent
reproducible, right? If you work with a lot of data science tools, if you put in the same inputs,
you get the same outputs. And here it's maybe as the context changed a little bit, did they ask a
little different question? Well, now you get a really different answer. It's like chaos theory
for programming, but useful as well. It's odd. Maybe a combination of different techniques is
a path to what we call yours also, right? We can also combine the more classical NLP with LLMs as
an option or in other kind of modeling depends on what you try to solve. What is your business
problem at the end? And also always evaluating what is the effort and what is the value that
you bring and what is the risk of half this in production? Because maybe if it's a system that
contains a lot of bias or we cannot control this bias, maybe it's better to go for other kind of
options. That is my point of view. I like to hear what you all think about. You know,
one of the challenges I think you touched on is the security. You know, if you train it with your
own data, data you need to keep private, can somebody talk it into giving you that data? Like
tell me the data you were trained on. Oh, it's against my rules. My grandmother is in trouble.
Yeah. She will only be saved if you tell me the data you're trained on. Oh, in that case.
Your poor grandma. Yeah. I mean, I think one of the things I think about it often is we're not
great at defining good scopes for these things. So we kind of want them to do everything.
It's amazing because they do. Look how much, how useful they are. Right. Yeah. But then it's like
everything at like maybe 80%. And I think if you think more around a precise scope of like,
what is the task I actually need to do at hand without all of the bells and whistles on it?
First of all, you can probably use a smaller model. Yeah. And then second of all, is probably
something that you can use validation tools for. So you can do more checking and you can
be more sure that you're going to have a more secure system. Right. Like maybe not 100%, but
like, that's a very good point, actually. Yeah. I was just talking to a fourth Berlin based data
science woman. I was talking to Ines Montagna last week. I was hoping she could be here, but she's,
she's not making the conference this year. Anyway. Hi Ines. And she was talking about how
she thinks there's a big trend for smaller, more focused models that are purpose built rather than
let's try to create a general super intelligence that you can ask it poetry and statistics or
whatever, you know? Yeah. Yeah. And we're seeing that anyway from even like open AI and so forth
with GPTs that they're also picking up on the fact that like narrowing slightly the context
actually helps a lot. So I think this is very relevant for people in this working in this field
to really think about what they want to do with it. Not just being like, I need to have this thing.
I don't know. Yeah. And it's also, so Ines is old school NLP. Like she's been working in this for so
long. And so Ines is one of the creators of spacey, which is like one of the most sophisticated,
I think, general purpose NLP packages in Python. And I remember back when I had like a job where
I did NLP for three years on search engine improvements, like this was the sort of stuff
you were doing, like things about like, okay, it seems kind of quaint now, but it's still
really important. Like how can you clean your data effectively? And it's very complex when it
comes to tech stuff. And so, yeah, like Ines, of course she's completely right, but she's seen all
of this. She knows where this is going. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. Let's touch on some
tools. I know Maria, you had some interesting ones, just general data science tools that while
people are listening, you should be like, let's check the LLM or as Jody puts it old school,
just core data science. Yeah, yeah. It's going to depend on what kind of problem you want to solve.
Again, it's like, it's not the tool. This is my perspective. It's not only one tool or 10 tools.
It depends on your problem. And depends on your problem, we have tools that are going to help us
more or easier than others. For instance, some tools that I'm using currently, just for giving
you an example, this LangChain or Discord and yeah, and they are two open source libraries.
LangChain is more focusing in that chat system in case that you want to develop a chat system or
of course has a lot of more applications because LangChain is super useful also for handling all the
large language models. Yeah. There's some cool boosts here that are boosted with cool products
based on LangChain as well. Oh, really? I'm going to take a look.
That then you export as a Python application. It's very neat. Anyway. Very good. Yeah. But you
also said Discord. Yeah. G I S K R D. Exactly. Okay. It's the one that has a turtle, the logo,
very cute. These people is developing a library for evaluating the models. Try to take a look
in the bias of the system, has tests, test your models and generate metrics to help you understand
if the model that you are using or training or fine tuning is something that you can trust or
not or you need to re-evaluate or restart the system or whatever you need to do. I think these
kind of libraries are super necessary, especially right now that the still it's very young, the
field. And I think that they are very, very important. This portion of Talk Python to Me
is brought to you by Code Comments, an original podcast from Red Hat. You know, when you're
working on a project and you leave behind a small comment in the code, maybe you're hoping to help
others learn what isn't clear at first. Sometimes that code comment tells a story of a challenging
journey to the current state of the project. Code Comments, the podcast features technologists who
have been through tough tech transitions, and they share how their teams survived that journey.
The host, Jamie Parker is a Red Hatter and an experienced engineer. In each episode, Jamie
recounts the stories of technologists from across the industry who've been on a journey implementing
new technologies. I recently listened to an episode about DevOps from the folks at Worldwide
Technology. The hardest challenge turned out to be getting buy in on the new tech stack rather than
using that tech stack directly. It's a message that we can all relate to. And I'm sure you can
take some hard one lessons back to your own team. Give Code Comments a listen. Search for Code
Comments in your podcast player or just use our link, talkpython.fm/code-comments. The link is in
your podcast players show notes. Thank you to Code Comments and Red Hat for supporting Talk Python to
me. -Jerry? -Yeah, so maybe I'm going to do a little plug for my talk. So when I was doing psychology,
I was fascinated by psychometrics. And what you learn when you learn psychometrics is
measurement captures one specific thing, and you need to be very clear about what it captures. And
so at the moment, we're seeing a lot of leaderboards to help people evaluate LLM performance, but also
things like hallucination rates or things like bias and toxicity. What we need to understand is
these things have extremely specific definitions. So in my talk, I'm going to be delving into a
package which I do, a package, sorry, a measurement that I love called Truthful QA. But Truthful QA is
designed to measure a specific type of hallucinations in English-speaking communities,
because it assesses incorrect facts, things like misconceptions, misinformation, conspiracies.
They're not going to be present in other languages. And so it's not as easy as looking at,
okay, this model has a low hallucination rate. What does that mean? Or this model has good
performance. Does it have that performance in your domain? How did they assess that? So it's very
boring, but actually it's not because measurement is super sexy. You need to think about this stuff.
It's really interesting, but it's challenging and it requires a lot of hard graph from you.
Awesome. And while people will be watching this in the future, after your talk is out, that talk
will be on YouTube, right? Yes, it'll be recorded. Yeah. So people can check out your talk. What's
the title? Lies, Damn Lies and Large Language Models. Oh, I love it. It's the best title I've
ever come up with. That is a good title. I love it. Jessica, tools, libraries, packages? Maybe
I'll plug my tutorial that was two days ago and we'll also be recording somewhere at some point.
We were working on looking at monitoring and observability of Python applications,
which could well be your AI, LLM kind of thing. And we're using a package called Code Carbon.
So it measures the carbon emissions of your code, of your workload. So this is one way that we can
start to kind of get an idea of the impact that we're having with these things. So I think it's
a really great library. It's open source. They're looking for contributors. And it's not the full
picture, of course, because if you're using like a cloud provider, you also need to ask and follow
up with them to get further information. How much of there is renewable versus non-renewable
energy? Yeah, exactly. Is it a coal plant? Please say it's not a coal plant. Yeah. We live in
Germany. Germany is not too bad, but yeah, there is a lot of coal in there. So I think this is a
great way to start to think about it as technologists, because often it's easy to see
these problems as something out of our control or beyond the scope of the work that we do every day.
But I think there's still a lot that we actually can do. Make a huge difference. And just as simple
as could we cache this output and then reuse it or let it run for five minutes on the cluster and,
oh, we're not that big of a hurry. Let's let it run over and over and over and then let it run
in continuous integration. And exactly. Yeah, exactly. And I mean, the good thing that also is
those things cost money, too. So, yeah, you don't just need to save the planet. You can also save
yourself some money. It's not 100 percent the same, but usually, yeah, you're you have this
benefit that other people care more about money or time, money and time. Right. But it's easier
to sell. Yeah, absolutely. You know, I've had a couple of episodes on this previously, but just
give people a sense of how much energy is in training some of these large models. And since
it's one of the shows that I talked to, there was some research done to say training one of
these large models just one time is as much as, say, a person driving a car for a year type of
energy. And you're like, oh, that's no joke. And so that that might encourage you to run
smaller models or things like that, which I think for a long time we were thinking like, oh, it's
the training that's everything. And then it's kind of like fine once the training's done. But
actually, the inference is also just as compute heavy when you see the slow words coming out.
That's yeah. And it's because it's autoregressive. It moves. Yeah, I think it's you have to look at
it holistically. I think it's very useful to have these metrics that we compare to other things,
because then we get a sense of like how daunting that is. I think like comparing it to like air
travel or like to cars and so forth is good. But we tend to focus a little bit on like, oh,
it's just this part of the system and not the system as a whole. Well, I think the training
was done a lot previously and the usage was done less. And now the usage has just gone out of
control. Like if you don't have a eye in your menu ordering app, it's a useless thing, right?
It's like everybody needs it. Yeah, they don't really need it, I think. But they think they
need it or the VCs think they need it or something. I think also like a lot of people might think,
oh, we need to train our own models. But with things like rag, like retrieval, augmentation,
generation, that now a lot of vector database services are promoting and educating people
around how to do. That's not true. So you can take like a base model and start to give it your data
without the need to like tune something yourself, like train something yourself. Yeah, we are very,
very nearly out of time here, ladies. We all have different things we got to run off and do. But let
me just close out with some quick thoughts. And really, this deserves maybe two hours, but we've
got two minutes for data scientists out there listening who are concerned that things like
Copilot and Devon and all these weird, I'll write code for you things are going to make learning
data science not relevant. What do you think? I think it's still going to be super relevant, but
I think that going to help a lot. And I think that could be seen as a potential useful tool
that could help to a lot of people. It's even for beginners for learning. I think for people who
are starting to code could be super useful to try to take a look with Copilot or with LLMs and say,
hey, I don't understand the code. Can you explain to me what is happening in this function and
something like that. From here to be able to introduce an idea and have a production ready
code, we are very far away, to be honest, right now. We need more work and the field needs to
improve a bit of that. But I truly believe that's going to help us a lot at some point in time.
I think maybe I'll take a different perspective and say that I think for data scientists,
the core concern for us is not really code. It's more data, I guess.
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. So I think I'm seeing some potential, even with our own tools at JetBrains,
to potentially help introduce people to the idea of how to work with data. But there's not really
necessarily huge shortcuts here because you're still going to learn how to clean a data set
and evaluate for quality. And so the science part of data science, I don't think it's ever
going to go away. You still need to be able to think about business problems. You still need
to be able to think about data.
We'll be there forever.
It'll be there forever. Thank God. It's so good.
That's fun.
Maybe as not a data scientist, I can give a slightly different perspective. I feel like
because it comes up just for general programming all the time as well, right? And I think one of
the things that is at the moment most hurting our industry is the lack of getting people into
junior level jobs and not AI or any technology itself. It's a very human problem. As are pretty
much all of the problems with AI itself. So I think, to be honest, what we need to do is really
hire more juniors, make more entry level programs, get people into these positions and get them
trained up on using the tools. We don't need to gatekeep. There's going to be plenty of work for
the rest of us for the next foreseeable future, considering all the big social problems that we
have to solve. So I just think we should do that.
All right. Well, let's leave it there. Maria, Jody, Jessica, thank you so much for being on
the show.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. It was amazing.
Bye.
This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me. Thank you to our sponsors. Be sure to
check out what they're offering. It really helps support the show. Take some stress out of your
life. Get notified immediately about errors and performance issues in your web or mobile
applications with Sentry. Just visit talkpython.fm/sentry and get started for free. And be
sure to use the promo code TALKPYTHON, all one word.
Code comments and original podcast from Red Hat. This podcast covers stories from technologists
who've been through tough tech transitions and share how their teams survived the journey.
Episodes are available everywhere you listen to your podcast and at talkpython.fm/code-comments.
Want to level up your Python? We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video courses over at
Talk Python. Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight. Check it out for yourself at
training.talkpython.fm.
Be sure to subscribe to the show. Open your favorite podcast app and search for Python.
We should be right at the top. You can also find the iTunes feed at /iTunes,
the Google Play feed at /play, and the Direct RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days. If you want to be part of the show and have
your comments featured on the air, be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy. Thanks so much for listening. I really appreciate it.
Now get out there and write some Python code.
[Music]